ja wir haben diesen elmar zirkus gehabt
ich glaube zum zweiten mal bereits und
im desaster von dem fernsehen schaute
hin und dachte das ist ja wie früher im
kommunismus die leute treffen sind alle
einer meinung und wie üblich bei solchen
veranstaltungen wird das schluss
communication am anfang verfasst und
zwar nicht von den teilnehmern sondern
von sogenannten sherpas den leuten zu
arbeiten und das ganze ist eine
darstellung des un- getan laut darüber
nach wie wilder sex gesagt dieses
spektakel hat 166 millionen euro
gekostet was eine unglaubliche summe ist
aber für andere ist es peanuts wenn wir
den chinesen 450 millionen euro
entwicklungshilfe schicken sondern sind
160 millionen euro wirklich nicht so
viel das waren 18.000 polizisten
unterwegs die leute in der gegen haben
sich beklagt weil das ganze leben zum
stillstand kam und ich habe es so
empfunden mit meiner hysterischen
überempfindlichkeit wie eine
generalprobe für den polizei statt es
wurde alles still gelegt dass private
sicherheit über alles andere und dann
bin ich doch ein bisschen getröstet
worden weil ich ein zitat von olaf
scholz daher seit medium auf allen
seinen wegen ein zitat von olaf scholz
gefunden habe da hat betont dass er die
zeit mit seiner ehefrau britta ernst
beim gipfel genossen habe sie merken
worauf ich hinauswill beim g7-gipfel ja
für uns war das natürlich schön dass wir
zusammen sein konnten sagte scholz denn
wir haben beide sehr in der
terminkalender wenn man das was man
politisch zu tun hat verbinden kann
damit dass man zusammen ist dann ist das
etwas ganz besonderes sagte olaf scholz
jetzt wissen sie was zu elmar gut war
das war eine paartherapie für die
schweiz
eigentlich waren die geissens dafür
vorgesehen aber die waren schon
ausgebucht also meisten gefreut das
finde ich und sehen das damenprogramm
herr bruder dieses nordic walking
die damen
ich war nicht eingeladen jetzt weiß ich
aber
okay der bruder ich wollte da hab ich ja
noch nicht alles soziale konflikte
ja es gab einen damenprogramm dein frau
makro und die frau von herrn scholz
diesen zusammen nordic walking gegangen
darüber haben sich viele beschwert dass
dass wir die rolle der frau ist beim
g7-gipfel die dem entsprechen die frage
an sie wie fanden sie denn das
damenprogramm also das hat mich
interessiert ehrlich gesagt also dass
das kenne ich ja auch wahr g20 schon
also das ist für mich wie vor stelle ich
gesagt ja wenn ich auch sagt überflüssig
finde ich schön wie die sich treffen
aber wenn dann so gezeigt wird also aber
ich sehe es nicht ganz so wie sie weil
ich finde schon dass die auch
miteinander reden müssen 100 prozent
finde ich auch dass es zu teuer das muss
auch nicht in ellmau stattfinden was
schon finde ich auch so für die deutsche
bevölkerung die jetzt wirklich unter
chor ohne wirklichen gott hat sehr enger
schnallen müssen und muss noch mehr tun
hat er schon ein symbol würde ich auch
sagen würde komm runter schalten oder so
bin ich aber dass sie sich treffen
miteinander reden finde ich das finde
ich wirklich wichtig weil in
videokonferenzen kann man das so nicht
besprechen und wir haben ja im fernsehen
alle mitverfolgt dieser so geschlendert
in und sich unterhalten haben und so ich
glaube schon dass da auch ich sage ja
partner finale
wurde ich jetzt nicht endlich mal
wirklich alles ist schon wichtig dass
die miteinander reden und ich finde das
auch als botschaft an russland nicht so
ganz unwichtig dass das der putin sieht
da kommt ja nicht dazwischen und das
finde ich jetzt von daher gesehen dieses
mittel sitzer flotte nun die schotten
dicht aber was er wollte ist uns
auseinander bringen wenn er mal wieder
sieht dass das nicht schafft ist das gut
dass da jetzt nicht sowas 1000 prozentig
neues rausgekommen ist okay nichts kann
man nicht sagen ich finde schon im blick
auf die ukraine haben die sich schon mal
wieder meer geeinigt und ich glaube das
ist für herrn scholz auch nicht ganz
unwichtig dass er sieht also hier der
beiden der will das auch wirklich und
die müssen sich dann habe ich auch
gegenseitig bestärken ich finde so ein g
7 ist schon das richtige also ich muss
sagen in welchen der fdp weit zu bringen
überhaupt nicht das hat der schaden aber
ist
[Gelächter]
ihren worden rochelle mans elmer war ein
kompromiss sagen wir zwischen
bahnhofsmission und im gran hotel
irgendwo ist dazwischen helmand warum
findet das nicht auf einem kreuz schiff
statt irgendwo in der sie warum ich auf
einer insel borkum und helgoland würden
sich wahnsinnig für ihn geht es ums geld
mit neuer ware natürlich ins geld ich
bezahle ist ja ich weiß nicht wie sie
ihre steuern vermeiden ich trage
und dann ich bitte sie was haben sie
gemacht haben der ukraine versprochen
sie als kandidaten aufzunehmen das war
vorher schon klar und im übrigen glaube
ich nicht dass sie sich treffen müssen
wie treffen sich alle naslang die können
das ganze interzum erledigen die kölner
ist das gerade da ist das auch nicht es
ist doch wirklich so ich finde es auch
mal okay wenn die sich auch mal
menschlich kennenlernen ich finde das
damenprogramm auch ganz okay aber gut
der gebäude über all das ist natürlich
schon verstören und 18.000 polizisten
wussten vielleicht auch nicht sein aber
ich bin auch der meinung g7 muss einfach
sein bin ich total ihrer meinung einfach
mal ein bisschen auch wenn es nur die
beine von johnson sind aber irgendwie
paar muskeln wird man schon mal zeit
habe ich bitte sie das ist doch nicht
der grund der politik dass leute
zusammenkommen dann kann man den
gleichen kegeln beim meet nun sie da ein
lager das aber auch eine symbolik finde
ich und mir gut getan und ja ich habe
mich nicht gefreut sehen
da kann ich als sparfuchs zu sagen kann
man schon mal ein bisschen es woanders
steuergeld es ist sozusagen ein
schaulaufen der versage gewesen mit
seinen treffern nicht zurecht man kann
man eben der wahl vergeigt scholz hat
total versagt 55 jahren beim g 20 gipfel
hatte ich habe sie gewählt also
nein sonst und ist vollkommen ratlos
seine eigene partei es gegen diese leute
die es nicht schaffen ihr eigenes
geschäft zu führen weil europa führen
und übernehmen der bruder ist versager
nicht ein hartes wort für alle direkt
aber wissen sie noch was anderes sein
weil das wir haben hier noch ein das
würde ja bedeuten dass sie finden dass
die regierung geschäft jetzt keine
außenpolitik mehr zusammen machen
sollten weil sie in ihrem land ein
problem haben dass es eine schneidet ihn
ein nein gerade der first things first
wissen sie und wenn ich nicht imstande
bin mein zimmer aufzuräumen
sie nicht auffordern in ihrem haus
ordnung zu schaffen wenn es auch nur
weil probleme nicht gerade so groß dass
man hat gesehen zusammenrücken muss und
vielleicht auch einfach mal sagen muss
so wären wir nicht mehr sehr viel
zusammen rücken das nächste mal komme
ich mit ablauf und britta mit und wir
können zusammen
nein schauen sie die leute müssen es nun
weisen dass wir es können der einzige
der irgendwie einen guten eindruck
gemacht hat fand war tragen ich sag mal
so distanziert was gesagt
hat es auf den punkt gebracht und dann
war noch eine der kaiser von japan wie
heißt der kamikaze oder so ähnlich ja da
auch nichts gesagt dass der arme japaner
und wartet haften also ein verein zur g7
com und nicht sagen
dass ich da sitzen die leute und den
runden tisch und die fotografin
fotografieren einzigartige ereignisse
und dann geht die tür zu meiner
umgekehrt müsste er sein wenn es
relevant ist und wenn das wichtige 1
sprechen live stream livestream hat sie
das hätten sie auch gerne live stream
von gesehen gehabt für uns bürger ich
weiß ich verteidige so ein bisschen auch
immer das recht auf privatheit also es
darf besprechungen geben die in zimmern
stattfinden unter sich wo man mal
informell wo man mal sagt was man nicht
sagt wenn die kamera gerade läuft müssen
uns nicht in irgendwelche
verschwörungstheorien oder bösen
bilderberger und da wird ganz schlimm
ist besprochen ich finde es okay dass
das vertraut daran gibt ich bin auch
bereit dafür zu zahlen wenn es grenzen
des anstands einhält ja das müssen jetzt
nicht irgendwelche mit blattgold
vergoldeten stakes wie bei herrn ribery
in dubai sein aber wir sind auch nicht
vergessen es gibt ja manchmal auch
spannungen zwischen sogenannten
liberalen demokratien also herr broder
ist ja experte für island da gab es ja
mit großbritannien auch die sogenannten
kabeljau kriege ja und fischereirechte
wo die sich zum teil über den bug
geschossen ja jetzt ganz gut wenn die
mal zusammen besoffen im wald spazieren
gegangen sind oder nordic walking oder
da ihr die haben gar nicht das konzert
völlig für die lösung der konflikte
zwischen nord und südkorea gemeinsam
spazieren gehen sich dann die kante
geben es ist es ist auf bestimmte regime
wahrscheinlich nicht
generell haben wir ja so ein ganz
komisches puritanische zeitalter wo
jetzt schon über den urinalen steht
kenne dein limit oder und welche
kampagnen ich finde das gut
denn jetzt können wir mit geben wir
haben eine politische am tisch aufrufen
zu mehr alkohol kann also alles kein
problem aber kommt die
verkehrspsychologe sei es gibt ja so
orte wo bestimmte soziale regeln
aufgehoben sind und das ist ja auch das
rockkonzert oder das fußballstadion ist
und dass es ok wenn auch eliten orte
haben wo sie mal bisschen anders
miteinander das
g7 war gut ihn bestimmten grenzen des
anstands es muss wie gesagt nicht dass
ich jetzt nicht genau die abrechnung
angeguckt was da alles getan wurde mit
nordic walking oder was da der spesen
ist aber ich denke dass hält sich schon
in westlichen staaten den rändern und
das ist doch auch schön dass unsere drei
oder vier armen afrikaner eingeflogen
und die dürften dann onkeltom spielen
für dieser runde alter weißer männer das
ist uns egal das ist das ist erstmal gut
das ist das tollste der aus afrika kamen
mussten auch noch so tun als wären sie
dankbar sie mussten ja nicht kommt also
ich meine rechte hand ist gab einen
freiflug ja und aber ich mache doch
hellwach wo das zimmer 1000 euro die
nacht
natürlich würde nicht obwohl hinkommt
wenn ich ihn nicht umhin kommen will
wegen als hotelzimmer ist ganz ehrlich
wenn ich dann wäre nach new york werde
dann gehe ich doch nicht hin genau und
vor allen dingen würden wir wenn sie
sowas sagen dass man sie so behandeln
auch gleichzeitig unterstellen dass die
sich so behandeln lassen so als ob sie
irgendwie weniger werden als sie an also
ist es doch nicht sondern sie sind dahin
gekommen die warschauer sie nämlich bei
fand sich jetzt nicht panisch um
rassismus an anderen stellen das will
ich jetzt noch gewacht retis als alles
andere sich in serie aber das nehme ich
jetzt mal einfach so mit ich finde schon
die da ein zu lang mit denen zu sprechen
ganz gutes zeichen das müsste man
sowieso viel mehr öffnen als es jetzt
geöffnet ist das ist eigentlich die
frage für mich reicht hätte die sieben
wirklich reichen länder zusammen sitzen
und ich finde auch ein bisschen zu teuer
geld ausgegeben haben aber sich
unterhalten was ich wiederum gut finde
oder muss man sich noch öffnen und die
al-adli gesprochen haben war neu nicht
was sie beschlossen haben ist wo wir
gesprochen wissen wir zum glück ist das
problem aber das ist doch gut das ist
doch gut lassen sich doch mal
untereinander ja natürlich finde ich das
gut finden es gut wenn die politiker
zusammen sitzen und silbernen löffel bei
ihr der bruder ist ja so nicht
gibt es wieder den handy alarm bei bild
das könnt ihr wirklich wie ein
wohnzimmer vor ort ist wer bestimmt was
auf sich für gesang aktentasche tragen
so schleiche ich mich rein ja sehr
unauffällig bestimmte herrlich